it's gonna be good hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to zombie
skill trainer now this is a game for the
vibe where you shoot zombies all right
you sure what do you want a song and
dance number that's all the game is on
no okay let's get this on let's get this
going now zombie Oh zombie training
simulator that makes more sense than the
words that I said okay so I've been
playing it cuz it's fun and I'm gonna
show you what to do in the skills test
now in the skills test I've been doing
pretty good I'm gonna show you the crows
foot which is the only one that I've
done come on shut up there we go some
goddamn peace and quiet sometimes music
isn't the best sometimes it's nice just
to relax a little bit now I'm gonna put
this down cuz you don't need it I only
need me and my skills you ready
freaking one hah ah damnit missed that
last one now as you can see my score my
high score anyway is 0.99 3 now I don't
know why I'm talking in a southern
accent brother I missed on purpose but
but but but but anyway I'm gonna put the
strap on because it's probably not good
if I fling this willy-nilly but nah
damn it alright well I can do this a
little better
alright now you I'd be better off if I
just hit it on the first try on that
last one there but [ __ ] no no what are
we gonna do oh god I'm so scared
Oh got him what happens sighs well what
happens if I just throw my gun Adam no
goddamnit
ah everything is horrible damn it I just
got to get it on the first try it's hard
[ __ ]
oh you old bastard shut up
I can't hit him I can't do it I can't do
it
oh whoops sorry okay all right ah yes
you record okay so this is the
quick-draw basically you got a it's
called the crows foot because one back
there three over there it's like a crows
foot up in here
ah Wow so there's records for certain
guns these pistols are the ones that I
had in the beginning I should set that
where I'm not gonna forget it it's
through the floor and just it's the same
thing except if you hit it when you're
supposed to hit it ah new record on that
one - I'm global ranked 25 weak who
booing boo boo Inc blink okay got that
guy good I did it okay so this is all
this game isn't the only other game I
got it was shotgun I don't know there's
gonna work huh well about that okay oh
oh another rank up for Marquis mu I'm
the best okay so that is that I haven't
done it with this yet same as the other
one how do I do how did I do boss ooh
ain't that good whoa all right whatever
it's not it's not worth trying this one
because oh yeah it's not worth getting
this one because I did good with the
other ones but anyway that's only that's
only a little bit of what I wanted to
show you guys get get back to the safe
house where it's safe from these zombies
boink bank
bonk okay so the real game comes in on
survival and survival has these various
levels ghost town - sky hole and I'll
not try the forest because I've been
doing ghost town it's a little bland
little boring this looks a little more
interesting to me and eventually I'm
gonna unlock these other weapons that
are gonna be super cool Oh
can I have my speech first please and
thank you
okay alright so this is where I need the
other one because is
where things are gonna get a little
dicey I've never done it with this
before um so I guess let's get to it
what is this gonna do for me ha whoa why
does that blow up I had no idea those
things were so dangerous mm-hmm yeah
okay so obviously survival is just they
come at you you kill them whatever what
have you boring boring boring but it
doesn't get boring because then a giant
horde of them appears from beyond the
horizon boink boink hey welcome to the
party I'm sorry about the [ __ ] throw I
meant that to be a little more manly who
don't even think about it don't do it
don't you even think about you GRU what
you going to do huh
black black black I hold a shotgun like
this this proves how strong I am blah
blah Blau and how badass and gangster
ish I be also you may notice that I'm
not wearing my jeans in my shirt because
I'm for gone looking good for the sake
of being comfortable but then you could
see these gangs were who wouldn't want
to see these guns get gains ah there on
the hill days are coming boss yet that
actually is kind of scary I mean not
right now but I just have a funny
feeling that they're all gonna be on my
ass in no time black black black black
black black black black black black
black black black black lamb lamb lamb
blam blam blam whoa hello hi oh okay I
guess I can't pick that up fine bling
bling Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong Bing
bong Bing bong Bing okay got that hey
get a little closer buddies I need to
see you here not there fine what a bunch
of dill weeds got [ __ ] dee dee yeah I
get it you're dead
alright so the basic point is that you
throw these meat out and they're
attracted to the meat so basically that
sets up trap areas so that they only go
there and not eating my face off which
is really what I don't want in my life
right now it is bad for me that's a lot
of them
but watch yes I was actually a good
throw
I am vastly impressed with myself that
was astonishingly good you think you
they would send more after me I mean I
don't know booth organized if the zombie
Union is here huh humming ah ha girl no
no no no no nope nope no no nope nope
nope nope no Newton yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
no that's my steak I'm gonna cook it for
dinner later don't you even try to steal
it from me
oh they don't seem to be after my meat
oh there's the ground all right come at
me bro come at me come on kill me I'm
here I'm right here you floating
bodyless Ami's oh hello
where do you guys come from now you this
is why I got extras so I can have extras
is there busy with that one and they're
gonna be done fairly soon like right
about now
funk soul brother huh look good
I was gonna do that midair and it was
gonna be super sweet but then it didn't
happen sooo not my fault yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo dawg my business then it make no
move Mook fat I'm not back back there
and you get double points for getting
multiple kills in a row so things like
this weapon is actually quite good at
doing the thing that that is Oh are they
going for the steak are they going for
me hard to tell sometimes huh Oh No
look out what's gonna blow oh I tried to
warn the sorry Souls it doesn't even
seem that if it matters me aiming or not
because it seems like they're just gonna
be hit by it no matter what it's a great
sweeping shotgun like device oh my god
they ass loaded they sometimes like to
push the meat
the greedy bastards uh get get some
furball oh that was there we go
some more fireball up BAM that didn't
get really anybody but it doesn't matter
goodbye I guess they're running off into
the woods now oh no you so dumb ah
got ya Oh tricked you you thought you're
gonna get a free meal but you got a free
meal of blood
what were you [ __ ] whoa [ __ ] bro [ __ ]
yeah get off get off get off get off get
off
whoa okay OOP some of them want me some
of them want me whoa some of them want
me good thing I do a little bit of melee
okay
gotta start blasting them gotta start
blasting them gotta blast got a move or
not going for oh hello
oh you're going for that good good
because I was gonna blast all over you
all right did it yeah whose victory man
on me to me maybe you think it's me it's
better to shoot them when they're all in
a line in case that wasn't obvious to
everybody but the youngest been watching
man you need to roll em up together
together
boink okay did I Do's it Oh who's left
ah that's slightly terrified oh hey
how's it going I thought that was gonna
be some big giant zombie peering out
from over the rocks over there you guys
has made it easy on me alright bring it
on blue boy seems like they're all
getting really close to me and then
detouring immediately whoa you're not
you're not you're not yo call god damn
it that's mildly terrifying came up
right on my ass whoa number 19 baby
number 19 [ __ ] you I'm not doing that
again
[ __ ] that okay where am I good I was
still on camera that's a success in my
book so this game is really fun
I've already sinned been playing it for
a while cuz just my face is sweaty Oh
probably a huge red marks everywhere but
thank you everybody so much for watching
there's always more virtual reality
games coming out in the near future so
let me know which ones you want me
and which ones you would like to see
thank you again everybody for watching
oh also before I go let me let me show
you this thing while I was in New York
uh we had a competition to make tacos
for Rachael Ray I don't know why but she
was there and we had a little taco
competition and I was in charge of
making the cocktails so I was making a
margarita and our team won best cocktail
so how about that the whole team let me
take the trophy comb home but it was a
team effort because they sang about it
so I can't remember exactly who was on
the team but thank you everybody for
joining me and thank you everybody for
making me win the greatest
conversational piece anyone can ever
have because I took it to the
after-party and everyone was very
curious so thank you again everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
buh-bye yeah I'm a little curious as to
why
are you what the [ __ ]